[Music]
in tonight's whatever happened to
segment the remains of American war
heroes returned from North Korea
for a while there looked like there had
been significant breakthroughs but this
evening Lucas Tomlinson at the Pentagon
tells us the outlook has changed it's
been more than six months since North
Korea turned over 55 boxes containing
the remains of some of America's heroes
from the Korean War our boys are coming
home
they are known but to God but soon we
will know their names but North Korea
hasn't turned over anymore since the
dignified transfer in Hawaii
according to dr. John Byrd the chief
scientist tasked with identifying them
of the 7500 missing Americans more than
two-thirds remain in North Korea with
the others further south we would be
delighted if we could get more remains
turned over to us but there's been no
discussion in the last you know since we
received the 55 boxes in his first
summit with President Trump
North Korean leader Kim jong-un
committed to recovering more American
remains including the immediate
repatriation of those already identified
the subject never came up in public
meetings between President Trump and
Chairman Kim in Vietnam only three
American soldiers have been identified
from the boxes so far but dr. Byrd says
more Americans will be identified in the
days ahead we're in the final stages of
making several more identifications
right now we're looking at four dr. Byrd
says based on DNA results up to 80% of
the remains turned over our Americans
ultimately dozens more are expected to
be identified Byrd describes some
painstaking methods American soldiers in
the Korean War would have had a very
different diet so when we look back at
the stable isotopes in the bones we can
actually recognize American remains from
these isotope occurs in the bones while
Byrd is eager to have more remains from
North Korea he understands it will take
some time for the details to be worked
out Shannon Lucas Tomlinson at the
Pentagon thank you